foreign
foreign
good morning
you
um
good afternoon
and begin by recognizing
both
dr breyer
dubai
and uh
for being here
and uh
i can't tell you this is sort of a
bittersweet day for me
justin brown and i go back a long way
all the way back to the
mid-70s when he first came on the
judiciary committee but that's another
story
i'm here today to express the nation's
gratitude to justice stephen breyer
for his remarkable career public service
and his clear-eyed commitment to making
our country's laws work for its people
and
our gratitude extends to justice briar's
family
for being partners in his decades of
public service in particular i want to
thank his wife dr joanne breyer who is
here today and who has stood by him for
nearly six decades
and with her fierce intellect good humor
and enormous heart i thank you the
country owes you as well
and stephen breyer's public service
started early
he served in the united states army as a
teenager
and in all three branches of the federal
government before he turned 40.
and as he was a law clerk
justice
a prosecutor in the department of
justice
a member of the watergate prosecution
team
and i first met steven breyer when i was
a senator on the judiciary committee
and uh he uh started off as
taking care of one of the subcommittees
for teddy and then he became chief
counsel
during his tenure as uh as
ted's chairman of chairmanship of the
judiciary committee
beyond his intellect and hard work and
legal insight he was famous for biking
across washington virtually every day
for a face-to-face meeting with the
republican chief counsel the ranking
republican council
and over breakfast they discuss what
would they do for the country together
whereas in those days we try to do
things together
the
that spirit stuck with me when i took
over the judiciary committee as chair
after senator kennedy's tenure
and uh it was my honor
to vote to confirm justice prior to
serving the united states supreme court
the court of appeals first in 1980
and then 14 years later in 1994 i got to
preside as chairman of the senate
judiciary committee over a supreme court
confirmation hearings we were joking
with one another when he walked in did
we ever think that he would have served
decades on the court and i'd be
president united states from the day he
came in to retire
and he looked at it anyway i won't tell
what he said i'm joking but i was proud
and grateful to be there at the start of
this distinguished career in the supreme
court
and i'm very proud to be here today
on his announcement of his retirement
you know during his confirmation
hearings way back in 1994
nominee stephen breyer said quote the
law must work for the people
he explained to us his faith that our
complex legal system has a single
purpose
tell people
who make up our country
it was a different time of course
but his brilliance his values his
scholarship or why judge breyer became
justice briar by an overwhelming
bipartisan vote at the time
today justice prior announces his
intention to step down from active
service after four decades four decades
on the federal blessing 28 years on the
united states supreme court
his legacy includes his work as a
leading scholar and jurist in
administrative law bringing his
brilliance to bear to make government
run more efficiently and effectively it
includes his stature as a beacon of
wisdom on our constitution and what it
means
and through it all justice briars worked
tirelessly to give faith to the notion
that the law exists to help the people
everyone knows that stephen breyer has
been an exemplary justice
fair to the parties before him
courteous to his colleagues
careful in his reasoning he's written
landmark opinions on topics ranging from
reproductive rights to health care to
voting rights to patent law to laws
protecting our environment and the laws
to protect our religious practices
his opinions are practical sensible and
nuanced
it reflects his belief that a job of a
judge is not to lay down a rule but to
get it right to get it right
justice breyer's law clerks and his
colleagues as many of the press here
know describe him and his work ethic his
desire to learn more his kindness to
those around him and his optimism for
the promise of our country
and he has patiently sought common
ground and built consensus
seeking to bring the court together
i think he's a model public servant in a
time of great division in this country
justice breyer has been everything his
country could have asked of him
and he's appeared before when he
appeared before the judiciary committee
almost three decades ago
we all had high hopes for the mark he
would leave on history the law and the
constitution
and he's exceeded those hopes in every
possible way
today is his day
our day to commend his
his life of service and his life on the
court but let me say a few words about
the critically important work of
selecting his successor
choosing someone to sit in the supreme
court
i believe is one of the most serious
constitutional responsibility a
president has
our process is going to be rigorous
i will select the nominee
worthy of justice briar's legacy of
excellence and decency
while i've been studying candidates
backgrounds and writings
i've made no decision except one
the person i will nominate will be
someone with extraordinary
qualifications
character experience and integrity
and that person will be the first black
woman ever nominated the united states
supreme court
it's long overdue in my view
i made that commitment during the
campaign for president and i will keep
that commitment
i will fully
do what i said i do i will fulfill my
duty to selected justice not only with
the senate's consent
but with his advice
you've heard me say in other nomination
processes that
this that constitutes seek the advice
and consent but the advice as well of
the senate i'm going to invite senators
from both parties to offer their ideas
and points of view
i'll also consult with leading scholars
and lawyers
and i'm fortunate to have advising me in
the selection process vice president
kamala harris she's an exceptional
lawyer former attorney general of the
state of california former member of the
senate judiciary committee
i will listen carefully to all the
advice i'm given
and i'll study the records and former
cases carefully
i'll meet with the potential nominees
and it's my intention my intention to
announce my decision before the end of
february i have made no choice at this
point
once i select a nominee i'll ask the
senate to move promptly on my choice
in the end i will nominate a historic
candidate someone who's worthy of
justice breyer's legacy and someone who
like justice breyer will provide
incredible service on the united states
supreme court
justice pryor
on behalf
of all the american people i want to
thank you and your family and your
family for your tremendous service to
our nation
i'm going to yield the floor to you mr
justice
thank you mr president that is terribly
nice
and uh
believe me
i hold it right here
it's wonderful and i i thought about
what i might say to you and i'd like to
say something i enjoy is talking to high
school students
grammar school students
college students
even law school students and and
they'll come around and ask me what what
what is the what is it you find
particularly meaningful about your job
what sort of gives you a thrill
and that's not such a tough question for
me to answer
uh it's the same thing
day one almost
up today i don't know how many
but but the the what i say to them is
look i sit there on the bench
and after we hear lots of cases
and after a while
the impression it takes a while
i have to admit but the impression you
get as you know as you well know
this is a complicated country
there are more than 330 million people
and my mother used to say it's every
race it's every religion and she would
emphasize this and it's every point of
view possible
and uh
it's a kind of miracle
when you sit there and see all those
people in front of you
people that are so different in what
they think
and yet they've decided
to help
solve their major differences
under law
and when the students get too cynical i
say go go look at what happens in
countries that don't do that
and that's there i can't take this
around my job
people have come to accept this
constitution and they've come to accept
the importance of a rule of law
and i want to make another point to them
i want to say look
uh
of course people don't agree
but we have a country
that is based on
human rights democracy and so forth but
i'll tell you what lincoln thought what
washington thought and what people today
still think it's an experiment
it's an experiment that's what they said
and joanna paid each of our
grandchildren a certain amount of money
to memorize the gettysburg address
and the reason the reason that that what
we want them to pick up there and what i
want those students to pick up if i can
remember the first two lines is that for
four score and seven years ago our
fathers brought up uh
created upon this
uh here a new country a country that was
dedicated uh to uh
liberty and the proposition that all men
are created equal conceived in liberty
those are his words and dedicated to the
proposition that all men are created
equal
too
and
we are now engaged in a great civil war
to determine whether that nation or any
nation so conceived and so dedicated can
long endure
see those are the words i want
to see
and experiment
and that's what he thought
it's an experiment and i found some
letters that george washington wrote
where he said the same thing it's an
experiment
that experiment existed then because
even the liberals in europe you know
they're looking over here and they're
saying the great idea in principle that
it'll never work
but we'll show them it does
that's what washington
and that's what lincoln thought and
that's what people still think today
and i say oh i want you and i'm talking
to the students now
i say i want you to pick just this up
it's an experiment that's still going on
and i'll tell you something
you know who will see whether that
experiment works
it's you my friend
it's you mr high school students
it's you mr collins student that's you
mr law school students it's us but it's
you
it's that next generation
and the one after that
my grandchildren and their children
they'll determine whether the experiment
still works and of course i am an
optimist and i'm pretty sure it will
does it surprise you that that's the
thought that comes into my mind today
i don't know
but thank you
doctor i don't know that you've ever
been to the white house in the lincoln
bedroom
i invite both of you to come and stay
the lincoln bedroom has
against the wall between the windows
looking out
a handwritten
copy
of the gettysburg address written by
lincoln
in that bedroom allegedly because i said
the sitting room
and so you got to come and see it and
even if you can't come and say bring
your grandchildren so they can see it as
well
thank you all so very very much for
being here and i'm not going to take any
questions because i think it's
inappropriate to take questions uh with
the justice here he's still sitting on
the bench
and
uh but you'll have plenty of
opportunities to get me later today and
for the rest of the week next week too
so thank you very much
thank you mr president